welcome back as mentioned at the top of
the show the FBI has raided the home and
office and even a temporary hotel room
of President Trump's personal attorney
Michael Cohen among the items reportedly
seized our documents related to
president Trump's alleged affair with
porn star stormy Daniels and get this
the feds reportedly got the search
warrant after receiving a referral from
Special Counsel Bob Muller the president
responding forcefully earlier today I
just heard that they broke into the
office of one of my personal attorneys
good man and it's a disgraceful
situation it's a total witch hunt we're
talking about a lot of serious things
with the greatest fighting force ever
and I have this witch-hunt constantly
going on for over 12 months now and
actually much more than that you could
say it was right after I won the
nomination it started this is the most
biased group of people these people have
the biggest conflicts of interest I've
ever seen and back to my question at the
top is this a major overreach or a
strong sign that Trump's attorney is in
serious legal jeopardy a whole lot to
unpack here so let's bring in former
deputy independent counsel during the
Bill Clinton whitewater investigation
Saul Weissenberg Harmy Dillon an
attorney and RNC committee woman for
California and former Secret Service
officer NRA TV contributor Dan bungee
know we have so much news to get you
guys let's start with you saw to raid an
attorney's office home and temporary
hotel room talk about the threshold you
have to clear in order to justify that
type of raid this is an extra ordinarily
aggressive prosecution move this is
controlled by the US Attorney's manual
Laura you're only supposed to do it if
less intrusive means like a subpoena are
not available or won't work
you have to go to not only the US
attorney the US attorney in your
district that would be New York City but
you have to consult with the Criminal
Division then there are all kinds of
rules you have to follow having to do
with review of the material I can tell
you this is very unusual and it's even
more unusual to my understanding from
the reports were they specifically were
looking for some communications between
President Trump and his attorney that
makes it even rarer and to do it when
the attorney is the attorney for the
President of the United States is is
quite amazing now it's too early for us
to tell you know whether it's right or
wrong or valid but I can tell you it is
outstandingly aggressive Dan the
president was just on fire about this
today I mean I don't think I've seen him
that mad publicly for what he said was a
witch-hunt
a disgrace that he repeated his
frustration with Jeff Sessions the
Attorney General your take on this well
Laurie you know you opened up the show
and asked is is Michael Cohen in legal
jeopardy let me answer you Laura we'd
all be in legal jeopardy if Bob Muller
was after us
mother Theresa would be in legal
jeopardy if Bob Muller was after us
because the federal criminal code were
all federal criminals I promise someone
paid a penny less in taxes at some point
in their life and is a federal criminal
no matter how good you are this is a
scam this total this case is a complete
total witch on Laurie just think about
the double standard here right let me
just frame this up for you they raided
Donald Trump's actual attorney his
personal attorney's office to go and get
evidence yet when Hillary Clinton was
interviewed her staffer who went to law
school but wasn't her attorney sat in as
her attorney so they could wink and not
of each other she was also a potential
co-conspirator Cheryl Mills and they
were allowed to keep evidence from the
FBI the computers after they looked at
them if that's not a double standard you
know justice is implied it's dead now
and it's really sad what's happening
Harmeet we were trying to look for
instances in which maybe lawyers for the
mob or you had their offices raided I
mean it is as Saul said and Dan's
expressing his frustration
unreal to have the feds go in and seize
a whole bunch of documents with
apparently a clean team you know as to
like separate the privileged material
out but boy talk about chilling a
relationship between a client and his or
her lawyer if this is what the feds need
to do to get the goods on someone your
reaction as a as a practicing you have a
rights attorney Laura this is outrageous
an unprecedented I've said it on your
show before but conservatives haven't
paid enough attention to the rights
guaranteed by the Fourth Amendment of
the Constitution and to cease any
attorneys communications with his client
are outrageous and I can tell you as a
lawyer who handles trade secret cases
sometimes you go to the US Attorney's
Office you go to the FBI you report it
it's hard to get their attention they
certainly don't act as quickly as this
and so they're giving extraordinary
attention to this and the timing of this
is not accidental as the other guests
have mentioned I think that the fact
that the IDS report is coming out soon
the FBI that may guarantee some heavy
scrutiny and potentially some
prosecutions over there maybe this team
wants to distract away from that but the
other thing is the president is exposed
right now because he's missing one of
his lawyers and he's been looking to
hire new counsel who wants to be the
lawyer who has their life disrupted
because they happen to represent a
client and whether it's the President or
not who's in the who's in the crosshairs
at the FBI so this is a chilling effect
and this is the same field office of the
FBI in the same u.s. attorney's office
that didn't lift a finger and didn't do
a thing on the Clinton Foundation with
almost a billion dollars plus a foreign
money pouring through there the double
standard is staggering and this is a
potentially a constitutional crisis
being set up here it is no no never said
anything like it I've never seen
anything like it look I've been around
here for a long time I was a practicing
white-collar criminal defense attorney
saw and the president today I mean I've
known him for quite some time I want to
play a sound byte from what he said
cameras rolled in let's watch the
Attorney General made a terrible mistake
when he did this and when he recused
himself or he should have certainly let
us know if he was going to recuse
himself and we would have fused a put a
different
Attorney General in so he made what I
consider to be a very terrible mistake
for the country and yet the other side
they don't even bother looking and the
other side is where there are crimes and
those crimes there again talking about
the double standard saw he seems to be
in reportedly more angry at sessions and
rod Rosenstein than he isn't mauler
I mean Muller says you know special
counts are trying to find crimes or
evidence of crimes pushing the envelope
but he will not let go of this just jeff
sessions both appointing Rosenstein i
think and then recusing himself from
this whole matter well I don't think
those comments make much sense remember
what Muller did here and I agree it's
extraordinarily aggressive we don't know
that it's outrageous or not and what
Muller did here according to these
reports he did was to go to Rosenstein
and say we have found something here who
do you want to handle it and Rosenstein
said you're not going to handle it I'm
gonna give it to the office with
jurisdiction so I don't think there's
any indication that Muller did anything
improper unless you think if he stumbles
across something that looks like a crime
he should just forget about it and not
tell anybody about it so it's very
aggressive yes it's not totally
unprecedented it's extremely aggressive
we don't know if it's outrageous yet
Laura you know they had to go to a judge
and they had to say to a judge we don't
know what do we do we know what judge
signed I can't go to it and go to a
magistrate and they had to say not only
is this probable cause of a crime and by
the way there's no Fourth Amendment
violation here and there are no special
rules for attorneys under the Fourth
Amendment but they had this almost
certainly would have had to have said
crime fraud exception applies or they
wouldn't have been able to explicitly
look at communications between Mike
Cohen and President Trump so they'll be
judged if they ended up lying in this is
a very serious force for President Trump
if he overstepped the line and this was
harm me it was getting to I think if he
overstepped the line on this and again
maybe they had probable cause I guess to
believe that Michael Cohen was shredding
documents so they had to go they had to
the subpoena wasn't gonna work
so they had to go do the raid I don't
know but there is no recourse here in
the political context I think that's the
point that's what makes this case even
more difficult well there's even less
recourse now because it's being
conducted not by Muller who he can fire
but by the Southern District in New York
his own has done a presumptive appointee
in there so it's even harder for him to
do anything about it now
alright this ten seconds each Harmeet
and Dan Dan first and harmie ice us all
I love your commentary you're always
lucid on these topics but I think you're
wrong you were arguing process here this
is about principle they are not
targeting a crime here they are
targeting Trump this was started to
investigate Russian collusion that never
happened everyone on this panel would be
a criminal if they were targeting you
instead of a crime army I pay my taxes
it's gonna say well the parent I think
the president made a mistake early on
with the appointments that he made I'm
afraid that he needs to look a little
closer to home he's had a lot of bad
advice from the beginning of his
administration on legal issues and on
his legal appointments and I think this
whole situation is an example of that
yeah where's chris Christie when you
need them and directly ahead thanks guys